you know the milk after like two sips
you're like starting to calm down a
little right it's ready for the next one
guys it's like
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Kevin Joe and
Nick Jonas together through the
grammy-nominated Jonas Brothers the new
album happiness begins the set to
release on June 7th followed by a
reunion tour the band's first in nearly
a decade get your tickets they're on
sale now guys welcome to the show thank
you so much and then here this is our
first ever trio episode we have a record
40 wings on the table any predictions
for how this will all end a little
aggressive yeah there is a spice called
the Hellfire on the table and I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna send it
[Music]
so we're starting here we're spicier or
classful hot sauce along the way we're
gonna hit da bomb
beyond insanity that's that seems
intense we're going for a ride
this is very good though I appreciate
that thank you had to rate hanging a
favor Jonas Brothers based off hot
sauces where would I fall Nick you're
very I think that you're double lows
calientes Caliente oh okay so I got some
room to improve yeah yeah we'll see how
it goes here okay so in addition to your
many top hits and enormous selling
albums guys have also written and
produced music for some of the biggest
artists in the world and when we had
John Mayer on the show
he talked through some of the chord
progressions that drive the biggest pop
songs and I'm curious when you look at
the Billboard charts right now do you
see any patterns any trends and the
types of songs that dominate on radio a
lot of funny wayward John Mayer yeah he
he did kind of copy a song of ours
little-known fact but you can look it up
on YouTube so the story is he came to us
and this is like Grammys years ago he's
like I love your song Love Bug which is
a bachelor's thank you the figures later
he released a song and the chorus is
literally the same without with the
different lyrics but it's a compliment
does that yeah did you spot that pattern
careful around your eyes yeah I was
about to say dude right out the gate
it's done um I try not to use my hands
but as far as us feels like we kind of
locked into something that feels
competitive with was on the radio but
it's totally within our world my lips
are already tingling so what's the
emergency protocol though I'm looking
around here it's like there doc you're
trapped on the show Nick you're your
hostage on hot ones I don't feel safe
I'd eat wings unlike your off time now
if I'm off the clock no whale wings no
way no wings even chilling hot sauce
interesting
you scandal so know that you guys have a
love for sports that goes far beyond
just sitting courtside at the Staples
Center Nick I'm curious when you spent a
week in spring training with the Dodgers
back in 2010 is there a story that
stands out and they didn't want him
didn't make the team yeah that was
amazing
so fine not a lot of people know that I
did that he's so excited he just sounds
like I was hangovers gone this is a
crazy story so we're playing the VMAs
back in 2008 there's this gag where it's
the stage kind of dropped around us and
his fans all surrounded us and it's like
two or three thousand fans we look out
and there's this hand above the crowd
and it's got a bunch of World Series and
it's Joe Torre coach and he goes boys
boys and it was like an out-of-body
experience I mean grew up in New Jersey
it's like you know babies in their
heyday that era we got to know him and
his family that came to more shows and
then one day casually he threw it out
it's like you want to come on to spring
training we'll get you in you know get
you out there so I I went out and they
they suited me up I got to take BP like
took some you know shag some fly balls
and Matt Kemp and Andre Ethier back in
that iteration last night we had a good
sports story as well we bumped into a
dog Beckham junior who we both were very
upset with because he just left the
giant right so does I usually what's up
guys and I mean of them like why why
he's like what is it why did you leave
us please sit why why but say go on was
there to it which was nice so you didn't
mean to take my money it didn't actually
if I said he was in short shorts right
was in short shorts yeah and he
beautiful beautiful cast I was right
behind great cast
[Music]
I had a pep talk before this was my wife
it's pretty good
she said done me down she loved spicy
food that's a really good I'm just gonna
take a picture of just sent her over so
she knows yeah what we're up against
whoa tell her to come on the show while
you're at it
I will she bowed crush anyone that comes
on yeah she's very spice level is insane
whoa ice totally bit when I see it so
when you guys are in the limelight as
long as you guys have been eventually
you just have to concede that you have
no control over the headlines and
sometimes an internet rumor with no
truth to it can spread like wildfire get
aggregated by 500 sites and then be a
trending topic on Twitter but here at
hot ones we're all about setting the
record straight
oh yeah so I'm gonna hit you as some
curious Jonas Brothers storylines and
you tell me if they're fact fiction or
if there's more to the story okay I love
it all right your team used to carry a
mannequin around on tour that would
dress up and close you're gonna wear the
next day even going so far as to match
the underwear to the outfit that sounds
like a good idea
it's not true but I think we should
probably start doing that great get a
real visual of what its gonna be all
right
fact or fiction two of you auditioned
for the role of Captain America and
First Avenger I don't think that's a
cure if you did but no I would've been
too young they offered it to me it's
just me didn't do it at the time fact or
fiction Joe Jonas needs a teleprompter
to remember Jonas Brothers lyrics
onstage
oh there's more to that story yes indeed
I just kind of said at this point when
we got the band back together I was like
guys I'm play the song in six seven
years and Nick loves to be like hey look
okay let's play this one tonight you're
like I'm looking at fans faces I don't
need to let you're like let's play this
one tonight so I'm like why do I give in
me like asking them for the lyrics and
that boys like all right screw it I'm
just gonna have these prompters onstage
and be shameless about it so I don't
need him for every song but
90% of the songs factored fiction Kevin
was called to testify during a 2017 FIFA
bribery scandal yes that's true actually
but you're not allowed to say anything
because actually no it's public jocket
oh yes yeah I just don't want to talk
about it
because I don't I'm nervous about
someone coming you let me say why are
you allowed to say why you had to go
yeah well because it's because of Joe
there's more to this story Joe his fault
so Joe was the one that was actually got
subpoenaed it's because he mentioned
that in a rolling star no strong sorry
that spice is starting to get in the
back of my throat a little bit um
Rolling Stone article that we were attic
Paul McCartney concert the day before
our concert well the way that I guess
the Attorney General wanted to prove
that this concert actually happened was
to prove that someone was there and the
way they can do that was by subpoenaing
Joe well he was out of country well I
was also there so I have to go in yeah
nerve wracking I imagine one more for
you guys Joe Jonas was responsible for
the errant starbucks cup that snuck into
Westeros in that recent episode of Game
of Thrones that would be amazing
I wish you just think about that that
would have been so incredible you like
basically [ __ ] something up a game of
things amazing
yeah I actually so asked Sophie like
good lady about that I was like so I was
like did you guys do that on purpose
like you know you try to do that cuz I
know there was a pickup truck and last
season I don't if he saw that and like
one of the fight scenes in the very back
there's like a white pickup truck
you start doing that just to mess with
the fans that she was like no like they
literally are like so meticulous about
everything but I kind of wish they just
left it in I guess the HBO took it out
now but it'll left Musudan orchard maybe
should just be an easter egg in every
scene
[Music]
I gotta get a good bite hmm I like this
one too
mm-hmm tasty not too spicy
oh it's getting there it's creeping yeah
it's a slow burn oh man what for him
this is bad sign and that was that that
was kind of ft damn we're dead so when
you're doing any sort of creative
pursuit let alone one under the umbrella
of a global powerhouse like Disney my
guess is that along the way you have to
pick and choose some of your battles
early on what are some of the things
that you're happy you pushed back on I
know even the Jonas Brothers name was
something you had to fight for yeah at
the Jonas Brothers name originally was
j-3 we had merged mopped up our first
concert we got on stage and we've looked
into another like we don't want to be
called j-3 because we weren't out there
doing dance moves and so we just got on
stage that hey we're the Jonas Brothers
instead of j-3 um I think at some point
like we just couldn't help but have like
five o'clock shadow and we're playing
like 15 year olds on we're like 19 on
Disney Channel right on the show right
so like we're like shaving every out
like every hour or every other hour to
be like teenagers on the show so that
was a little tricky as you can tell it's
a little hard what do you remember about
the Jonas Brothers short-lived punk rock
face mmm epic so extreme we were like
seeing kids from Jersey yet so at one
point like we were gonna see MxPx and
slick shoes you know all of those bands
like you know punching people in the
face and the mosh pit kind of thing and
Kevin did a backflip in a mosh pit twice
Wow and hit the same guy in the nuts
twice
and I watched Kevin I'm like he's gonna
get beat up like now this guy has every
right to fight him a guy who still was
like you know in like a mosh tha it's
all good I'm where Kevin deserves to get
his ass kicked right now
[Music]
los calientes calientes this video some
call it the Nick Jonas of hot sauces
alrighty so it's very Nick you actually
you're kind of right and spit out it's
like I can handle it for just like a
small amount of time alright guys we
have a recurrence segment on our show
called explain that Graham where we do a
deep dive on our guest Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context and for the third time in hot
ones history we have an allsports theme
so ray to show you the picture you guys
just tell me the bigger story does that
sound good yeah sounds good wow this
table big enough it might actually and
that even need you anymore bill did you
just fire someone on the show sorry do
you have a lasting memory from sharing
the cowboy sidelines with Buzz Aldrin I
did not want to take this picture with
us he refused you know I walked out I
said Mr Aldrin I was like to the mr.
Alden like such a big fan you mind if I
take a picture say no no pictures and
turn around I was like up which was a
great enough story and somehow I think
his PR person was like no you should
take this picture but he had us
baseships if you can see all over his
suit and he's a badass
alright can you give me the itinerary
what goes down when the Jonas Brothers
take over the Masters this is a
tradition a growing tradition we go in
on either Saturday night or Sunday
morning when we go for Sunday at the
Masters and obviously this year was
incredible with Tiger coming back to win
it all
I was on 18 what happened
say just let me drop that real quick so
ever heard that pick that up
also Michael Phelps commented on your
that's really cool I just saw that and
say so to say oh yeah that's so basic
that's then finally Nick here you are
taking batting practice and you really
make the rounds I got a lot of love for
a lot of teams anything that will have
me come to BP I'm a fan of that story
with this bar there yeah Alberto and his
wife have an amazing charity all around
ending human trafficking raising
awareness for human trafficking so the
last two years actually on my birthday I
performed a show at Angel Stadium and it
was you know for this cause and then
Albert was like why don't you come and
hit VP so Joe came out we took BP I got
two out
put two out of two out I got videos to
prove it
it just says hell on it I got a big
chunk of that mm-hmm
[Music]
that's more like I'm typically I'll stop
right there but not today not today
today oh it stays in there so you guys
have been pretty open about the role
that group therapy played in helping
bring you guys back together which is
something I think a lot of brothers and
sisters watching right now can relate to
can you talk through some of the
challenges in that process because the
way you guys have it is not under normal
circumstances you know like on one hand
you have this shared goal of bringing
the band together and then on the other
side of that you have a life in the
public spotlight where everybody's pokin
holes at the relationship all the time
I think deciding to get back together as
a band was like a lot for us because I
think for the longest time we just kind
of put stuff onto the rug we said we're
not gonna talk about this anymore let's
just move on let's rebuild our
relationship and our friendship that was
like pretty tough few weeks there where
we had to just open it but now it's
sorry the spices hit me now it's really
about like being as honest as we can
with each other and not like we used to
be sneaky with some of the
decision-making and one person would go
directly to maybe our management talked
to them separately than us and we'd be
like no we're a band we got to talk
about this also family first making sure
that we're all comfortable and whatever
we end up doing and that way we're all
happy at the end of the day and we don't
do this for anything other than reason
we want to [ __ ] is real this [ __ ] is
real this [ __ ] is real what the hell
it's like very um it hurt like it hurts
like I was literally looking down like
down over there for like an EMT just in
case like Alex oxygen tank it's
underneath your tongue yeah I'm just
getting that part - yeah eyes are
watering legitimate need to do this this
is a terrible idea
serious question sure what's the process
for using the restroom after this is
done I'm honestly concerned red-carpet
treatment here at hot ones we clear you
it's wait no I mean like hands can we
can't touch her faces so that's a good
point to bring up
thoroughly wash [ __ ] before and after
yes oh my god
getting real over here no she smells a
little bite ever oh damn oh my god okay
that's not I don't know how I feel about
this nut so from Taylor Swift walking
backwards to Jayden Smith wearing an
Ironman costume there are a lot of
creative ways celebrities use to evade
the paparazzi over the years do you guys
have a go-to tactic
what does Taylor dude walking she walks
backwards so you can't get the picture
or you have Jaden Smith who will wear
like a full Ironman costume
hold on this needs to be unpacked when
she walks back to looks like I got a
camera
so this whatever like this the bulbs are
going and then you just move yep you
just start walking backwards it's genius
Wow it was brilliant
yeah who taught her that there was one
day wasn't paparazzi as fans and
Argentina had surrounded the hotel to a
point that we actually couldn't get to
the show was unsafe and so we did just
they were expecting us to get in cars
you know like our service the ones that
were sitting up front so we just walked
to the back entrance of the hotel and
called a couple cabs and rolled straight
through in cabs because they were not
expecting it frightening in a moment but
hiding in plain sight hide in plain
sight
my lips are on fire literally it's
impossible to answer yes way getting to
like the Met Hotel like to get ready
it's like craziness I'm sure
and we citibike to the hotel and so I
just kind of like walked in and everyone
expected these like big party buses or
big SUVs so we me and Sophie just kind
of strolled in and by the time we're
like halfway in they're like oh [ __ ] and
it's a Gordon we're out of there so I
wreck
and city bikes there you go my little
crazy yeah I feel like very plump does
it hurt no just I feel like you know
don't worry about your sexy got three we
have three more
[Music]
oh man hey hey
a touch my lips a lot
mmm-hmm nope oh my nose nope says the
story goes a big part of bringing the
band back together was you guys filled a
bowl up with questions and then pulled
them out and we're all very honest with
how you answered them go ahead and
that's such a lovely segue to our
recurring segment with groups which is
the bucket Oh BFF questions and so
here's the way it works you just reach
into the bucket you asked aloud and then
the other two brothers will answer Nick
with Larry I couldn't chew that yet
bring it on your eyes are so red oh my
god okay
it's got a half-life coming so if as
you're feeling now the worst you're
gonna feel somebody
yeah throw up keep it together man yes
they got Hanson out for this we got to
be better
whoa this is so crazy for those of you
at home watching this is totally a
authentic reaction oh my god
I don't you can't use your hands as you
can walk can't do anything should use
clubs for this oh my god
nice coming down right coming down
it's got a half life
what's one complaint your significant
others have about me intimidating well I
like that I'd like that
um you're late I'm late you have the
most things yeah
[Music]
ah who does James Corden like the best
out of all of us he kissed my neck a
couple times yes he likes yesterday I
kissed his ring yesterday
yeah I'd presented his ring and I kissed
it felt really strange but oddly right
oh right
you guys were reaching for one more I
thought you're gonna say the wings and I
was gonna walk out all right
be honest what was your immediate
reaction when you heard jay-z rap no I'm
not a Jonas Brother I'm a grown-up no
I'm not a virgin
I used my cojones I thought that was
awesome yeah little did jay-z know I
used my cojones since before that joke's
on you jay-z fact check your stuff
oh my god mmm so good
[Music]
I'm just saying no that's fine your did
you're out it's down to you and me do it
do it we're in this together
there you go baby
I can even bite off it I got it in my
mouth though hmm you look crazy yeah and
then looked over your eyes are bright
red and you're like tearing up you're
gonna be a mean it's awesome great a
million internet meme him so your
careers have taken you around the world
I know that New Jersey has a very
special place in your guy's hard for the
uninitiated can you explain a Jersey
style hot dog Kevin take it away cuz
Kevin never got out of Jersey there are
a bunch of places that you can go for
hot dogs you got like Coney Island you
got Nathan's you got that stuff but in
Jersey to a place like ruts Hut that is
just amazing some grill some boil lose
the potatoes in teh toes corn inside you
know I'm a huge fan of the fall and then
you go up towards like apple picking
stuff like that and they have the apple
cider hot dogs you know it's all in the
apple cider like the liquid which is are
you still talking about hot dogs you
told me to take it away I'm really
impressed you look like you didn't know
what to say and then you were like then
you boil the dog and you can put in
water you can put him on ice yes who
would win and her brothers cookout Joe I
know that you once that dream to go into
culinary school I did um why is why are
you doing that
[Music]
all right do you putting more on I'm
dribbling out my mouth I'm not calling
you a [ __ ] I'm asking if you're putting
more on can I spell it
go ahead give it a smell are you a [ __ ]
damn this is the one this is yours
brave psyching yourself out so thick the
last dad were ducks mm-hmm the last dab
and the reason I was shaking it up
Kevin is because of the tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
week you don't have to if you don't want
to come on give it to me Kevin go come
on Kevin Kevin you made it this far
buddy do you want to see me come on I
would love to see you cry
I was just crying Oh keV come on it's
like The Avengers over here dude Thor
give up the Captain America give up
[Music]
take away to have that bit do people
like just eat this for like their normal
wings I think pretty probably throw
parties right yeah they do this they do
all the time we get those videos all the
time go on YouTube look up hot ones
parties whatever I get that to be good
at me every day because hot sauce is one
of those things you always wonder could
I say it's like watching your show as
often as I have I'm like like really
they're acting it up and then I get it
now
I'm sorry Shaq I'm sorry Kevin Hart here
we go alright that was that hot sauce
diesel kaufold oh that one's like that
one just alright guys here we are at the
summit of Mount Scoville we are at spicy
winged Valhalla place that very few
people have ever been before and it's
such a beautiful moment you guys back
together about to go on tour and we just
set a hot one set record by taking down
40 wings to give this very special
episode the send-off it deserves with a
little game so I asked you a question
and then I will count to three and then
you guys have to answer that question at
the exact same time we'll see if the
stage presence the stage chemistry is
still there or if there's some cobwebs
we have to dust off its seafloor exit
for a little bit yeah it's in there what
song are you most looking forward to
playing at the reunion tour one two
three burn you the city you're most
looking forward to plane is blank one
two three all New York City and finally
who handled the worst today between
these three brevin one two three Kevin
a unanimous decision but you made it of
the undying on look how much more I took
of that than they did no you know
knatterton I'm not trying to hold it up
in a way that I'm bragging about it but
play you Kevin do you my man but look it
but complete Kevin Joe and Nick all the
way down the spicy wing gauntlet and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you guys this camera
this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life oh so here just ate some
wings I got some wings I have an album
coming out June 7th after that it's
fourth of July my birthday is August
15th at Joe Jonas make sure to hit me up
it's all mouth look at look at it I'm
doing the Kylie challenge they're like
if they clap they'll stop hurting thank
you thank you for having us on that's so
fun we've had some of you hey what's
going on hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans checking in to say thank you so
much for watching today's episode but I
have a stern warning for those of you
out there who've been watching us now
for nine seasons and have still not
subscribed this is your final warning
subscribe or else
[Music]